- WHAT FLAVOR YOU GOT?
- VANILLA.
FLAVOR DO YOU GOT?
- LEMON ZINGER.
- LEMON ZINGER LIKE THAT TEA?
- OH.
- WHAT?
- OH, NO.
- NO-NO.
- I GOT THAT BRAIN FREEZE.
- OH, MAN. THE [bleep] YOU DO.
YOU AIN'T NO BRAIN FREEZE.
- OH.
- MAN, DUDE. RELAX, MAN.
THAT [bleep] PASS, MAN.
CALM DOWN.
- IT AIN'T PASSING.
OOH. IT'S INTENSIFYING.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN NOT PASSIN'?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN, MAN?
THAT CAN'T BE INTENSIFYIN', DOG.
- WHOO.
- COME ON, MAN.
YOU SAY YOU FROM THE HOOD, DOG.
YOU ACTIN' WEAK RIGHT NOW
WITH THIS BRAIN FREEZE.
- AHH! OW!
- COME ON.
AIN'T NO BRAIN FREEZE GONNA MAKE
YOU YELL LIKE THAT, MAN.
GET OVER--DON'T BE HITTIN'
YOUR HEAD WITH THE BRAIN FREEZE.
COME ON. HEY. YO,
YOU GOIN' SILVER BALLS ON THAT?
SILVER BALLS ON A STRING,
KINETIC ENERGY.
- PLEASE SHUT YOUR--
- WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
COME ON. OKAY, EXORCIST.
WHAT ARE YOU DOIN' NOW?
WHAT, YOU DOIN' SOME KUNG FU?
GET OVER IT, MAN. LISTEN.
IT CAN'T BE DOIN' THIS MUCH
TO YOU.
LISTEN, MAN.
DON'T BE A PUNK ASS BITCH, MAN.
GET OVER THE--WHAT,
ARE YOU AFRAID NOW?
YOU SEEIN' THINGS?
YOU JUST SCARED?
BRAIN FREEZE MAKING YOU SCARED?
- WHO ARE YOU?
- OH--WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
"WHO AM I?"
YOU AIN'T GOT
NO ALZHEIMER'S.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU.
- HELP.
- YOU A PUNK ASS BITCH.
WHAT IS THIS?
YOU GOIN' THREE STOOGES
ON THIS [bleep].
THIS IS SOME CRAZY ASS--OH,
YOU EVEN DID THE HAND BLOCK.
YOU KNOW WHAT, MAN?
YOU'RE WEAK, MAN.
YOU A WEAK ASS [bleep].
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
'CAUSE YOU'RE--
- MMM!
- OH, WHOA.
YO, YO, YO, YO, YO, YO,
YO, YO, YO, YO, YO.
HOLD UP NOW. HOLD UP NOW.
HOLD UP NOW.
HOLD UP NOW. HOLD UP, MAN.
YOU GONNA CONTINUE
TO EAT THE FROYO EATIN'
ON TOP OF THE BRAIN FREEZE?
WHAT ARE YOU DOIN', DOG?
HEY, NOW I'M REALLY STARTIN'
TO RESPECT YOU NOW, MAN.
IF YOU GONNA EAT THE THING
THAT'S CAUSING YOU THE PAIN?
THIS IS GREAT.
OH, OH, NOW IT'S GOIN' FASTER.
NOW YOU'RE SPEEDIN' UP.
HE'S STEERIN'
INTO THE BRAIN FREEZE.
THIS [bleep] IS STRAIGHT
CRAZY RIGHT HERE, DOG.
HEY. REAL TALK, THOUGH?
REAL TALK, THOUGH?
REAL TALK, THOUGH? I MEAN,
THIS CRAZIER THAN THE TIME, MAN,
THAT I STRANGLED BENNY
WITH MY BARE HANDS
'CAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE MY MONEY.
- ALL RIGHT. WE GOT 'EM.
- GOT WHO? WHAT?
WHAT? YOU 5-0?
- STAND UP SLOWLY.
- WHAT? I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
MAN, I KNOWN YOU
SINCE THE 6TH GRADE.
- YOU UNDER ARREST FOR THE
MURDER OF BENNY TACTERATRICS.
GET HIM OUT OF HERE.
- HEY, MAN, YOU A PUNK ASS
BRAIN FREEZE [bleep].
- AND YOU GOIN' TO JAIL
FOR A LONG TIME.
I'M IN TOO DEEP.
AHH.
I GOT THE BRAIN FREEZE.
GOT CAUGHT WITH
THE BRAIN FREEZE.
- YEAH,
YOU GOT THAT BRAIN FREEZE!
- GET HIM OUT OF HERE.